[Musique]
calais maupin bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors on
l'a appris il y à quelques heures plus
de cas désormais aux états unis qu'en
chine
quel est l'état d'esprit des américains
il dit en effet il ya plus de cent
soixante trois mille personnes aux états
unis qui ont sur des cas confirmés de
décor aux navires réussies et il y avait
plus de 2000 160 morts du virus
il est également important de comprendre
que à new york city dont je vous parle
nous sommes au centre de la crise il y a
des dizaines et des dizaines de cas
confirmés c'est très important c'est une
crise massive des actions sont prises
notamment l'arrivée de ce navire que
vous avez vus à l'écran
donc il ya beaucoup d'action donné
beaucoup d'efforts et le gouverneur de
l'état de new york dit que l'association
est bien pierre évalué l'état n'était
pas prêt alors vous lisiez un ces images
ont d'ailleurs fait le tour du monde
l'arrivée de ce bateau militaire hôpital
dans la baie de new york avec me lie à
l'heure où nous parlons
quelle est la situation sanitaire aux
états unis navire contient effectivement
lille lit et 12 salles d'opération des
opérations pourront être menées sur le
bateau pour sauver des vies mais un
problème aux etats unis c'est que nous
manquons de respirateurs et des
arrangements ont été conclu avec general
motors general electric des entreprises
afin de produire plus de 50000
respirateur au cours des 100 prochains
jours
de plus l'institut de technologie du
massachusetts travail sur le
développement d'un respirateur à bas
coût qui coûtera on l'espère moins de
100 dollars et il ya vraiment beaucoup
de demandes pour les respirateurs donald
trump a même dit que si la production
respirateur suit les plans tels qu'ils
existent aujourd'hui
alors ils enverront des respirateurs en
france en espagne et en italie afin de
les aider dans leurs efforts
il ya également des problèmes au niveau
du dépistage beaucoup de gouverneur
demande la mise explosion de tests pour
dépister la population mais il n'existe
pas encore selon eux et ils sont très
critiques envers donald trump
il ya également beaucoup d'optimisme à
propos du projet apache qui est un
partenariat privé public entre
l'entreprise entreprises américaines la
république de chine et le gouvernement
américain la chine s'apprête à envoyer
des masques heures par exemple 10,3
millions de gants et des thermomètres
donc ce projet à briscoe a commencé et
les premiers sont les premières
fournitures sont arrivés samedi et c'est
une source de l'espoir car on sait
maintenant que des respirateurs son
produit hors masse tonale trump a fait
jouer l'acte de la production totale de
guerre qui lui permet de réquisitionner
des actions au niveau de l'industrie
alors vous nous le lisier un instant un
risque de pénurie beaucoup de production
de deux respirateurs notamment pour y
faire face
dans le même temps les états unis ont
décidé de venir en aide
également en europe notamment en italie
avec 100 millions de dollars dead
médicale en quoi cet acte de solidarité
est important pour les états unis
les etats unis se rende compte que
l'italie a reçu de l'aide de la russie
de la chine de cuba et cl aux etats unis
nous ne les étais pas également alors
cela serait très mauvais pour leur
propre réputation les états unis veulent
s'assurer qu'ils ne font pas de
solidarité qu'ils font croître de
solidarité avec l'italie comme
les autres pays l'ont fait il ya eu un
appel
yvon mondiale pour que la les états unis
lèvent leurs sanctions contre le
venezuela l'iran et cetera parce que
cela exacerbe la situation dans ces pays
les états unis sont la cible de beaucoup
de critiques au niveau international
pour leur renforcement des sanctions et
de l'isolément économique et qui entrave
la capacité de ces pays à recevoir des
aides économiques il y à une lettre
commune de beaucoup de pays qui ont
écrit aux états unis pour leur demander
de mettre un terme à ces sanctions
bilatérales sur les paysans question
parce qu'ils essayent de mobiliser et
d'obtenir des de l'aide médicale afin de
lutter contre ce virus et éviter la
propagation du la pandémie mais mc
pompéo le secrétaire d'état américain à
un système pour qualifier le virus de
virus chinois ou de grippe de mouran et
continuer à essayer de diaboliser la
chine et sa population
donald trump semble être plus amicale
envers la chine
en tout cas mike pompéo insiste et
continue à blâmer la chine pour la crise
et veut renforcer les sanctions sur deux
contres des états qui ont vraiment
besoin tête alors pour conclure vue des
états unis
quelles conséquences cette pandémie peut
avoir sur les relations entre les états
unis justement et l'europe
sims b il semble qu'il y ait de grandes
divergences au niveau des états unis et
les démocrates et les libéraux
critiquent l'administration donald trump
ils disent que les relations entre les
états unis et l'europe sont essentiels
mais certaines personnes dans le parti
de donald trump qui est ce que les états
unis devraient au contraire renforcer
leur isolement avec l'union européenne
il ya beaucoup de controverses et on
redoute des conséquences sur l'économie
américaine
on observe de près les marchés boursiers
il ya eu un programme de relance mais
les banques sont vacillent les
hypothèques ne sont pas remboursés et à
un américain sur cinq a déjà perdu son
travail en tout cas une source de
revenus importante donc les conséquences
économiques sont très très grave et
donald trump a préconisé la des dépenses
très élevées pour renforcer les états
unis après la crise une fois que la
pandémie disparaît en espérant que cela
pourrait renforcer l'économie
mais en tout cas les états unis et sont
vraiment au bord du gouffre après le
désastre du coffee 19 et cela pourrait
avoir un impact sur les relations avec
l'union européenne
merci beaucoup caleb maupin bon courage
dans votre confinement à new york city
je rappelle que vous êtes correspondant
rt aux états unis